[Music]  Taylor Swift reflecting on her  sexual-assault trial one year later this  day year ago was the day the day that  the jury sided my favor and said that  they  I just wanted to say I'm sorry to anyone  who ever wasn't believed because I don't  know what my life taken if some people  believe me when I said that something  had happened to me the 28 year old was  on stage in Tampa for a reputation tour  stop a jury found former DJ David  Mueller liable for assault and battery  for allegedly groping Taylor back in  2013 what I'm saying is that I didn't do  what they say I did while Mueller has  denied the claims Taylor was awarded the  $1 she counters before or after he  claimed she cost him his job Taylor  couldn't help but get emotional about it  [Music]  and I wanted to say I'm just I'm so  happy to see you one to have you  [Music]